welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Ronaldo Funes Juan's otay he is here
at Yale as the Henry Hart rice family
foundation visiting professor at the
McMillan center professor Funes is an
associate professor of history at the
University of Havana he is the author of
from rainforest to cane field in Cuba
the award-winning environmental history
of Cuba since the age of columbus today
we'll talk with Professor Funes about
sugar cane and agricultural
transformations in Cuba welcome
professor Funes thanks for having me
here today thank you very much you are
welcome you spent a majority of your
work on sugar cane the sugar industry in
Cuba how did you come to study it what
led you to it I stood in the University
of Havana from nineteen eighty six to
nineteen ninety one you can imagine that
moment was hard moment because all the
change in the communist countries and
when i began to to work I went to the
history of science center and this was
in the moment of the great collapse of
the Cuban sugar industry in the Indian
itís and I want to do a different kind
of history about the sugar because
during my studies in the University of
Havana I made a mighty seas about you
were born in a traditional way and I
went in the middle of this contest of
the crisis of the United to to do a
different kind of history to rewrite the
Cuban sugar history and link this with
the environment environmental issues
okay because from that moment I want to
to to do to work with environmental
history as environmental historian and
for me was very important this different
point of view to about the Cuban sugar
industry what were the environmental
implication of this process of the
a truer industry in Cuba from from the
beginning but mostly during the nineteen
and twenty century okay so give us an
overview of what you found they connect
you know between the environmental
issues and the sugar industry I think I
want to emphasize the dependence of the
environmental conditioning in Cuba in
this process of the spansion of sugar
industry from from the beginning with
the slash-and-burn system of cultivation
of the sugarcane depending of the cuban
forest because the forest was i think
maybe the most important thing in the in
this expansion of the sugar industry
because forest supply with timber of of
course with a firewood and mostly with
the fertility of the Cuban soil they get
fertility of the queue and soil many of
the Cuban soil depend of the forest in
in that bombing and I want to follow all
this process from from the beginning to
the 20 center of the process of the
deforestation of the Cuban planes and
for me was very important to emphasize
this in the middle of that a context of
the decline may be definitive decline of
the Cuban sugar industry at the end of
the 20 Century okay so in the processing
of sugar cane does deforestation occur
tell us a little bit about that so in
the beginning that's how sugarcane yes
from the beginning this depend because
Cuba was covered by Forest when the
Spaniard arrived almost all the Islander
is different estimate about the amount
of forest a mostly tropical dry forest
and rainy forest but mostly tropical dry
forest and from the beginning the truer
opened this forest to cultivate the
sugar cane that you are industry and
from the beginning the sugar industry
was a kind of a industrial enterprise in
some way because you need to to produce
the sugar in the in decide in the same
place where do you have the sugar cane
fields now okay and from the beginning
this has this
characteristic and at the same time the
use of slave labor first from from
Africa from the 17th century in Cuba to
the end of the 19th Center this sugar
production the pen of the slave labor
labor labor force and of course because
they forest and the Cuban environment
right so has much of the forest been
what percentage of the forest was lost
due to the sugarcane industry I think
most of the Cuban forest disappear
because the truer industry's expansion
of course there is the cattle ranch
different system of cattle ranch but
during the first centuries we had the
questions between the forest and the
cattle ranch in different ways now in
different a Cuba had a very important
shipbuilding industry in Havana during
the 18th century but this the kind of
deforestation was different because
truer need the soil mostly not not the
forest did the fourth in other ways you
know a way to use the soil and of course
to as a fuel for the sugar industry and
as a timber and this process began
around Havana and the spansion was
mostly two days of cuba until the
beginning of the 20th century mostly the
main a process of the first station
happen between the beginning of the 19th
century and the beginning of the 20th
century because a new fad rest in the
queue and sugar industry during the 19th
century the beginning of the process of
mechanization that was very early in in
Cuba compared with other country I told
this that Cuba was the birthplace of the
industrialized agriculture in the
tropics because the use of the steam
power from the beginning in the 19th
century very early in the context of the
first Industrial Revolution and in a
very close relation with the United
State from from that moment from the
1820s in Cuba a began a process of
introduction of the steam powered
machines machines
in different in different moments not
and this process not just the use of the
steam machines the use of rain trade
Road in Cuba was very early was the
second country in the cotton this
continent after the united state with
the railroad system and the use of
steamboat was very important also then
Cuba began this transition from the use
of animal animals and human labor force
very early in the 19th century using
these new machines from the first
Industrial Revolution and the main
supplier was the United States and that
moment a united state was the main
market for the Cuban sugar production at
the same time united states provide a
lot of machines a lot of foodstuff and
many timber for example and this
relation was really close from the
beginning in the 19th century Cuba was
the main market for the United State in
that moment compared with any other
countries in this continent compared
with Brazil with Mexico Cuba was the
main export to the United States and the
main market for the United States
production in that moment and very early
United States replace the presence of
the English in the queue on English
technology or French European technology
French technology in the Cuban in the q1
market and this is was a very important
relation between Cuba and the United
States from the 19th century okay so
what happened because early you
mentioned that the sugar industry
declined what led to the decline but the
decline was mostly in the 90s in Cuba
but you are a truer industry had a long
history during the nineteenth and
twentieth century almost 42 century two
centuries qo was the main is border of
this sugar cane to the world market and
mostly to the United States because this
a great dependent from the United State
market that began in the 19th century
remain unto the Cuban Revolution in
nineteen fifty fifty night and this
process are differing a moment no moment
of crisis moment of increase of the
sugar production
the the process of the deforestation
almost finished in the 1920s because
different reason because yes for that
mom and the sugar cover all the plane
areas of Cuba the the most suitable for
the sugar production and cue 14 s almost
disappeared complete not in the
mountains but in the plains areas and
the condition of production change from
that moment in the 20s but a qso ferry
road during the crisis of the threats
because this huge dependent from the
United State market and we had a great
decline in the sugar production in that
moment in the same way that during the
First World War we had the tremendous
increase the double in the sure increase
of the amount of the sugar production
during that moment of the first work
during the Second World War the
production was recovered again and we
had this different process of the
increase or decline in the sugar
industry but always remain as the main
source of the Cuban economy this kind of
dependence in relation with the sugar
production on to the Cuban Revolution
scoreless lahaina revolution another
important moment because the conflict
between Cuba and the United States in
that moment Cuba can
a sale sale anymore ada chewer to the
Cuban market and it was through in place
for the Soviet Union Chinese another
market but mostly for the sewing Soviet
Union more or less in the same level of
dependence he can compare with the
former level of dependence with the
United State more than seventy-five
percent of the cuban and sport or more
depend on the of the Shuar production
and cuba maintain this dependence of the
sugar industry until the crisis of the
90s and with these tremendous collapse
of the sugar production in that moment
well i did very laps and very different
condition because from the 50's in Cuba
of course to maintain this level of
production Cuba began to use more
fertilizers it was more dependent for
fertilizer who was more dependent for
for the mechanization to reply replace
the human labor mostly after the
Revolution and was more dependent from
this external input for the sugar
industry the use of irrigation for
example increase many times from the
moment of the revolution until the nidus
and of course this create a most
vulnerable never vulnerable to our
industry in that moment during the 90s
with the decrease of the oils
importation to to Cuba with the decrease
of all this kind of input that were used
in the shore industry of course the
situation was even worse every year and
this situation is today more or less the
same this process of the collapse the
great collapse of the Cuban sugar
industry because was most dependent from
this external input compared with the
process of the sugar industry in Cuba
until the middle of the 15th century
that mostly depend of the our own
resource but the resource of the forest
was the consequence the depletion of the
Cuban natural resource of this expansion
of the Cuban sugar industry so this Cuba
produced
sugar today yes to take you produce but
not remain anymore as the main source of
the Cuban economy after the 90s and now
the economy is more diverse e5 of course
we will have a very strong economy in
different ways but now we depend more
from tourists for example from mining a
nickel for example and for other
services that the Cuba provide to other
countries and Cuba depend in some way
from jewel remain at the main a crop we
had we have a tobacco of course that is
very important and other crops but sugar
remain as the main sport crop in in Cuba
and we had we have now some kind of an
effort to increase the Cuban sugar
production but I think not in the same
level compared with the with the path of
the q1 to our industry a mostly because
the situation of the marker is a change
from the night is to now because the
increase of the sugar production in
Brazil and in other countries anything
we need to to put the cue one case in
our context in the context of the
Caribbean a compared to our with Puerto
Rico with from Anakin republic with this
the same kind of process from the 50s
until the present and of course qra
remain as a symbol of the sugar remain
in Cuba in different discussion about
sugar about our history in relation with
truer remain today because for many
centuries or years I told about about
Cuba was told about sugar in less way
about tobacco but mostly about truer is
an example of one of the most dependent
country of this kind of cash crop
economy and of course dependent from the
slavery during the 19th century all
these social and environmental
consequence remain today in the Cuban
society and in the
one history mm-hmm so in looking in
during your work in the sugarcane
industry you you've also kind of
broadened your research to other areas
tell us about that yes I think for me as
environmental historian was very
important to began with the sugar
because sugar was the main cause of the
transformation of the Cuban environment
of the Cuban landscape and the Cuban
ecology but I want to continue this
study with other activities now I'm
study mostly about the cattle ranch in
Cuba about the livestock in general
about the nutrition the animal proteins
nutrition in relation with this a cattle
ranch because for me the presence of the
cattle ranch behind the Shuar it was the
second cows of the transformation in the
Cuban landscape and for me it's very
important also this relation between the
sugar industry and the cattle ranch in
the Cuban history we had we had a very
famous author in Cuba who wrote a very
famous a book about the counter point
between sugar and tobacco in Cuban
history okay but for me in different way
the real control point in human history
in the landscape in the Cuban landscape
is the counter point between shore and
cattle ranch because different reason
and also I want to emphasize the
relation between humans and animals in
the q1 in the key one history not just
with plant that are so famous as sugar
and tobacco and I want to talk about
animals in the Cuban history as the
center in the Cuban environmental
history and that's why I'm in the last
year and working more about this other
history other Cuban environmental
history in relation with the animals in
different ways because I want to talk
about the energetic transition in the
Cuban history this social metabolic
transition in the Cuban history either
in place of the human
labour force of the animal labor force
what are the implication the use of the
oil in the Cuban economy in the Cuban
society how this change the the long
term the Cuban history and the cumin
relation with this natural resource in
our Islands are our archipelago human
release an occupy right how do you think
Cuba will change moving forward
especially with its new relationship
with the United States yes I scene is
very important this new age in the Cuban
us relation in different ways and I
think of Korra we are neighbor we had a
really long history together and our
culture he has a lot for a lot from us
culture many Cuban live here in the
United State and we need to rebuild this
new age in the queue on us relation and
this relation will be very important in
these a concerns about the Cuban
agriculture about the Cuban environment
about Cuba as a market for the United
State production for example that this
was very important traditionally Q
Awards until the moment of the
Revolution the main market for the u.s.
agricultural production more than the 25
or all the sport from the United States
to Latin America went to Cuba and the
moment of the revolution in agriculture
a mostly and us provide a lot of food
stuff for the Cuban economy and for the
Cuban society and the Cuban people at
the same thank you i was so depending
from the united states because this
reason and we need to create a kind of
economy no so dependent from the united
state in the future but what of
caressing but we we need to to do this
kind of exchange in with a mutual
benefit between Cuba and the United
States and I thing is is possible in
this new new age and for me as
environmental historic is historian a my
main concern is with the Cuban
environment with the change change in
the queue
an environment because we have this kind
of history in the moment of crisis our
relation with the environment is better
in the moment of the good economy maybe
our relation with the environment is
worse and we need to take advantage of
the new opportunity opportunities in the
relation with the environment for for
the future anything to work together
with the United State will be very
important and of course Q is potentially
one of the main destination of the Cuban
tourist of the u.s. stories for the
future arwa us was in the past due unto
the 50s from the 19th to the 50s the
main destination in the Americas for the
u.s. tourists it was a Cubano and in the
future of course this will happen but I
prefer a kind of relation more friendly
with the environment for for the future
because we need to preserve this
environment but because the we depend of
the environment for this kind of future
in relation with trees with agriculture
we need to create our own agriculture
able to provide our necessities and of
course with a lot of tourists arriving
to Cuba we need more food we need to
import more food for this market but at
the same time will we need to create a
level of self-sufficiency in the Cuban
economy because we had this experience
with the different collapse in the Cuban
trade partners or relation in the in the
past as in denied it with the collapse
of the Soviet Union as the main part
partners for the Cuban economy and I
think we need to sing in all of these
and many people here are thinking about
this also it's a very exciting and
interesting time for Cuba yes of course
yes it's very exciting with change maybe
with more change in the future and I
think we we need some good things or
they're not so good but we need to work
together in general the cube
and cue one with the United States I I
prefer to say that it's time for a to
build bridges not a trenches not some in
some way as in the past knots and in
general I am optimistic of course we
need to to think in realistic way at the
same time very good thank you so much
for being here with you very much it's a
great pleasure to be here with you
Merlin thank you for more information
about professor Funes and his research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale